Fillie in latin we would say Philly's
gonna hook up gonna connect gonna touch
the comet it's really an extraordinary
thing and done by the European Space
Agency the mission is lasted 10 years I
think because the distances in space are
just enormous there's a lot of space in
space and for those of you have not done
this please visit Planetary org and look
at the photographs the pictures coming
back from this thing you can see what
people have speculated a lot about the
nature of cometary bodies comets and
asteroids is there not a single rock
it's a gravel it's a rubble pile as we
like to say these rocks are held
together by their tiny but nevertheless
nonzero amount of gravity just
rendezvous in with this comet is an
extraordinary thing it's it's a compared
to the vastness of space it's a very
very small object yet it is part of the
primordial solar system there's gonna be
something there that no one's ever
thought of we're gonna make discoveries
that no one's imagined yet and we're
gonna have this adventure this is the
thing about exploration when you explore
you're gonna have two things you're
gonna have you're gonna make discoveries
there'll be stuff out there that no
one's thought of something about ice
something about rock something about
gravity something about orbital motion
something about iridium I'm making that
up
something about elements that we don't
think about too much and you're gonna
have an adventure there's gonna be an
adventure landing the spacecraft
watching the object come closer and
closer that's gonna be exciting and as
we say all the time what do you guys
what are you guys gonna find out there
we don't know what we're gonna find
that's why we're looking and it's as I
like to always do I tie it back to the
only preventable natural disaster which
is the earth getting hit with an
asteroid for me practically you can see
that if you were to set off an explosive
here to try to deflect this thing if it
were if it were going to hit there this
one's not gonna hit the earth everybody
but if there were another one that
we're gonna hit the earth you can see
that if you just tried to push it you
probably wouldn't influence it properly
you just make it scatter and you might
make things worse so that's why we at
the Planetary Society advocate our laser
bees program where we sat the surface of
one of these with lasers but that aside
I hope to be among the people that does
not go the way of the ancient dinosaurs
there is no evidence at all that the
ancient dinosaurs had a space program
and it cost them